all right let's move on here it is world
wildlife day next week so we partnered
with las vegas territory to give you
a head start to celebrate let's go
beyond the neon
and into the wild
there's a different way to get wild in
vegas off the strip
and beyond the neon welcome to
lion habitat ranch we are here
with bentley here uh
he is a a barbary lion he is
14 years old and he weighs around 500
pounds so we have 31
lions here total we have emus and
ostriches and we have a giraffe we have
nevada's only giraffe here
and we have a parrot surround as well so
macaws and cockatoos
the lion habitat ranch is open thursday
through monday from 11 a.m to 3 p.m
it's family date and covet friendly so
you can book your tickets
online ahead of time we also do
streaming safaris on the weekends so if
you're watching on facebook you can
watch a live video where we do a fun
activity you can join along with and we
also
offer virtual field trips for
schools if you're not able to come out
and do a field trip in person
and we also do behind the scenes tours
that are a more personal tour than just
a general admission
and did you know that barbary lions are
actually extinct in the wild
so the lion habitat ranch is one of the
few places you can actually enjoy
these kings and queens of the jungle so
what does it take to take care of all
these animals
so we do give all of our lions a bath
and we use a nice warm water so it's
comfortable for
them curious yeah we bathe them with a
johnson's baby shampoo
whoa and the males we will actually
brush their hair
as well and they get a leave-in
conditioner too
oh taking care of the mane
i see that we're walking towards ozzy
the giraffe
beautiful this is the first and only
wrap in nevada
yes that's correct so what are his stats
tell us about him
so ozzy is a reticulated giraffe uh he
is six years old and
when he stands up all the way straight
he's about 16 and a half feet tall can
you show me how tall you are
wow very good and so it is uh ozzy's
birthday
coming up on march 7. he is turning
seven years old
wow so what do you guys do here at the
habitat on his birthday anything special
we usually have a big birthday party for
him
and i understand that ozzy is talented
yes he's talented he has many talents he
is a painting giraffe
so he does hold a paintbrush in his
mouth and paint pictures zookeeper megan
says there aren't a lot of animal
habitats in las vegas so it's a great
idea to explore what our las vegas
territory
does have to offer like the henderson
bird viewing preserve
camel safari and mesquite yes camels in
las vegas
and wild west horseback adventures in
moapa valley
see what's open beyond the neon with las
vegas territory just head to
explore.lasvegasterritory.com
we'll be right back right here in las
vegas